what I want to talk about III I want to
give kind of a an overview of this case
that's been before the Supreme Court I
personally have been wrapped up in this
thing because I developed one of the
metrics that was offered to the court as
a potential measure of partisan
gerrymandering and so what I'd like to
do is just give a high-level overview of
what the legal background of this case
has been then talk about the the
opportunity that this presents for
social science and actually computer
science as well for potentially
measuring what a gerrymander is then I'm
going to get into some of the metrics a
little bit into the weeds maybe not
enough for this audience but but but a
little bit into the weeds about about
what the different metrics are that have
been proposed to the court and what they
each kind of what aspects of a
gerrymander each one captures and then I
want to talk about how all of these fit
into the Gil V Whitford case that had
its oral arguments earlier this month
and then kind of where we go next from
there so the Supreme Court first got
involved in partisan gerrymandering with
a case called Davis V Bandemer in 1986
this is fourth for the first time the
court decided that in principle a
partisan gerrymander is justiciable
which means it's a question that the
court can make a decision about that
before that time they've been very
reluctant just to be involved in the
redistricting area in general there was
a lot of drama around an earlier set of
redistricting cases from the 1960s the
court had to ponder very seriously
whether they wanted to get involved in
those cases and then this was extending
that question of redistricting to the
the partisan gerrymandering space the
problem that the court had was that they
didn't really know
a partisan gerrymander when they saw one
they didn't have a standard for
identifying one and this is kind of
extraordinary I think because they made
it clear from the dicta and the decision
that they believed that such a thing
existed they just didn't know how to
define it and especially how to define
it in a way that would ensure that it
was that they didn't see a lawsuit for
every single plan and that whatever
decision they made in future cases they
could it was defensible as a neutral
principle so that it didn't end up
making the court look like it was just
you know pushing its thumb on the scale
every time so the end result of the case
was was a victory for the plaintiffs in
the sense that the court said yeah we
could decide this case in principle but
we're actually not going to intervene in
this particular case because we don't
know we don't you haven't prevent
presented us anything that seems
manageable as a standard for identifying
gerrymanders in the future this this
from justice white I think is telling he
says the mere fact that there is no
likely arithmetic presumption such as
the one-person one-vote rule that says
the standard that came from those
earlier cases in the 1960s in the
present context does not compel a
conclusion that the James the the claims
presented here are non-justiciable so
just because we don't know what the
measure is right now and it seems like
the measure is not crystal clear what
that measure would be doesn't mean that
there couldn't be a measure at some
point in the future but he also says the
idea that any interference with an
opportunity to elect a representative of
one's choice so any amount of partisan
shenanigans in redistricting though the
idea that that would be enough to strike
down a plan would open the door and
invite attack on almost all
reapportionment statutes so that's an
issue that the court is clearly very
concerned about this question of
manageability so what followed after
Davis and B Bandemer was 18 years of
failure where a variety of claims of
partisan gerrymander were brought to the
court and to the courts I should say not
to the US Supreme Court but just the
lower courts and they never even
advanced passed the preliminary motions
so they were just dismissed out of hand
as not as not being meritorious enough
to even go to full trial that string
broke with the case called Vieth viju
biller
in 19 2004 and in this this case
actually kind of laid in some ways that
it it continued the status quo of the
Davis V Bandemer case but in some ways
it altered it just slightly and it
certainly laid the the sort of laid out
the playing field for the case that we
just heard earlier this month so that
the difference here was that the the the
basic decision was the same it we could
conceivably have you know partisan
gerrymandering is justiciable we could
conceivably have a metric for for
evaluating such an idea but we don't
have it yet and so we're gonna leave the
door open the difference here is that it
became the decision became somewhat more
polarized where four justices said you
know what and what's interesting is
these four just even these four justices
it was the Conservatives on the court
even they said partisan gerrymandering
is the thing and it's probably not a
good thing so even they agreed that
there was such a thing and that in
principle it could be unconstitutional
but they said that the notion that you
could ever measure it effectively in a
way that could be managed by the courts
is insane and we're never going to be
able to do it so we should just vacate
ourselves from this area of the law
entirely and then four justices had each
hat they said not only could we
potentially strike down a plan but we
actually here's my particular proposal
for how we should do it so for actually
we're ready to offer their own standards
and then Kennedy embodied the spirit of
Justice Kennedy embodied the spirit of
Davis viburnum er and saying you know
what there could be such a measure but I
haven't seen it yet sort of the kind of
aspects of them ask the aspects of them
emerge in some of the other metrics that
i'ma talk about they're sort of a
playing field for these metrics and they
just different sorts of notions of a
gerrymander
so m'm idea of a gerrymander without
touching in some respect on some of the
metrics that have been proposed but I'll
get to that in a second so he says the
failings of the many proposed standards
for measuring the burden of a
gerrymander that gerrymander imposes on
representational rights make our
intervention improper so all these
standards stink we shouldn't get
involved if workable standards do emerge
however the court should be prepared to
offer relief there was one other Supreme
Court decision on this topic between
Vieth and the the gill case the Woodford
case that was just heard that was LULAC
V Perry it was very similar an outcome
and only came two years after the Vieth
decision and it was very similar an
outcome to the Vieth decision four
justices one to give up for one and had
their own standards and Kennedy has
hadn't seen the standard but he thought
there might be one they want one key
difference in the case of LULAC V Perry
is that there was an actual concrete
metric that was proposed to the court
that was this measure that all call
Gelman came bias with some people call
symmetry and it was proposed in it
wasn't even proposed by the plaintiffs
or the defendants it was proposed by a
group of political science professors
include Gary King is a very well-known
methodologist at Harvard and he and a
group of others proposed this this
metric completely from the outside and
they proposed it in favor of neither
party they just said here's something
you might be interested in using and the
the members of the court responded to
that brief and discuss whether they
thought it was valuable or not so but it
was the first time some concrete idea
had really been put on the table beyond
hey we have fewer seats than we used to
so we don't like this plan so the the
this this status quo that
the the Vieth in particular established
creates an opportunity for for the
social sciences and for like I say for
computer science as well to get involved
in this area presents and I think that
the the opportunity was stated quite
nicely by again Kennedy himself and beef
he says technology is both a threat and
a promise on the one hand if courts
refused to entertain any claims of
partisan gerrymandering the temptation
to use partisan favoritism in
districting in an unconstitutional
manner will grow again he's saying the
temptation to use it unconstitutionally
this thing that we don't even know what
it is right but dammit we're sure it
exists it's out there it's real we just
don't know quite you know how to define
it on the other hand these same new
technologies may produce new methods of
analysis that make more evident the
precise nature of the burdens
gerrymanders impose so please provide
ideas right that's that's as close as
you're ever going to get with the court
so why is it that this is such a hard
such a tough nut to crack well I think
it actually has to do with the
fundamental nature of our
representational system our system was
designed to represent Geographic places
it is a very district specific concept
so in principle you know if this system
were operating in its ideal form you
would have people in a particular
community who would elect a person that
they thought would be best able to
represent their interests that that
geographic spaces interests and that
that the interests of that Geographic
space would be generally shared by
everybody who lived there and the only
the only issue would be finding the
appropriate person to go there and
figure out how to represent those
interests in this larger body that
everybody feeds into right
so very very geographically focused but
everybody knows that's not really how
politics works it may be kind of how
people imagine politics in a party free
environment when the system was designed
but that's not actually how politics
operates and
at parties dominate politics and parties
are an inherently aggregate concept the
whole point of a party I mean a party
can't have a geographic component to it
but the whole the whole point of a party
is to is to find subsets of people in
each district that have common interests
and desires and bind them together into
a more or less permanent standing
coalition and then that coalition
marches together in the legislature on
issue after issue after issue and that's
aggregate it's not district based now
other systems get around this particular
problem by actually specifying an
aggregate vote seats relationship like a
PR system proportional representation
system will say hey for every 1% of the
vote you should get one percent of the
seats and that's specified at the
aggregate level there's no district
based component to it so the basic
problem is if votes the votes to see its
relationship at the aggregate level is
not specified in law then how can you
say that a party ever wins too many
seats all right it's not we're not even
supposed to have these things called
parties it's all supposed to be about
representing places right
but if voters care mostly about parties
when they're casting their actual votes
how can you say that partisan
manipulation can have no limits and so
when you think about it in those terms
that we have essentially layered a
partisan system on top of a basically
geographic system you begin to
understand that the challenge the
struggle that the court is facing when
they're trying to decide how much is too
much
right so this creates I think an opening
for social science it's a real
phenomenon that is complex
it requires systematic transparent
measurement in particular in this case
because that's the court really wants it
to be something where they it's
defensible as a principle right so that
so that and it when they're applying it
to any particular case they can say well
you know what there's we
we had this standard we'd evolved and
when we applied to this case here's what
it produces right it's not us we don't
we're not trying to make the Republicans
win or the Democrats win it's it's the
it's the the formula or the or the
standard so it's kind of a perfect fit
for social science but I think it's a
challenge for the courts and all and
I'll get into that and a little bit so
what are the metrics that people have
proposed I put on the table well the
first is this one that I mentioned
earlier
Gelman King bias sometimes called
symmetry the idea the basic idea behind
this is that equal parties should be
treated equally symmetrically that is so
if you receive the same share of the
vote if two parties receive the same
share of the vote they should receive
the same share of seats now the problem
of course is that usually parties don't
have the same share of the vote so what
do you do
in that case well you pretend as if they
actually did have the same share of the
vote this can be done a variety of ways
one way is for instance if the Democrats
have 60 percent of the vote and 70
percent of the seats then you pretend as
if they had 50 percent of the vote and
then see how many seats they get if they
have anything other than 50 percent then
there's potentially a problem a similar
idea would be to if they won 60 percent
of the vote to say what happens if the
Republicans won 60 percent of the vote
do they also win the same vote share
that RC chair that the Democrats did
when they had 60 percent of the vote and
there's a variety of versions of this
the most common I think is just seeing
what happens at 50 percent you can also
you can plot out theirs if you think
about sort of shifting this distribution
of districts around and seeing how many
seats flip as a result you can actually
plot out that yeah electro college is
actually not not a perfect space for
this kind of stuff for reasons I could I
can describe
this yeah so but the this is I'm just
talking about legislators at this point
so not not the Electoral College but but
but votes and seats and legislators yeah
yeah
so the you can you can actually plot it
out as what they call those seats votes
curve and then you can see whether that
curve is symmetric around the 50% point
for instance you can evaluate that
symmetry as far out to all the way to
the tails if you want to but but again
it generally it tends to be done right
around that 50 percent yeah so that's
actually that question of whether people
vote as partisans is actually not I
would say the biggest complication with
this particular metric it is a is a
question mark in terms of whether the
court should be involved in this area at
all right if if nobody votes in the
basis of parties there's not much point
in a partisan gerrymander and there's
not much point in striking down a
partisan gerrymander because it's not
gonna stick right but that's going to be
a but that's going to apply to any one
of these potential metrics yeah okay
there's there's versions that will allow
for some stochastic variation around it
but as a practical matter that doesn't
really change the results very much well
it does in the sense that the the
outcome that you have in any particular
election can be determined in part by
the candidates who are running yeah yeah
and so and so then the assumption of
this is that you can just shift that
entire distribution and again there's
some some randomness to that that you
can insert as estimated from the data
but but it doesn't tend to change that
result very much
so that the advantages of this I think
of this as as a really good measure of
majority rule so the party with a vote
majority deserves a seat majority
symmetry tends to be violated most
consistently when that doesn't happen
where where if hypothetically a party
lost its a vote majority it would not
necessarily lose its season majority
that actually happened in the in the
Wisconsin plan that's at issue in the in
the Woodford case so in that sense it's
really great at capturing majority
entrenchment it also is very flexible
about when we talk about that aggregate
votes to see its relationship it's very
flexible about what that relationship
might be otherwise beyond basically
requiring this this majority control
it's you know it it it says it you can
have you can have a really what what
they call responsive system where let's
shift in votes where there's a lot of
competitive districts and a shift in
votes produces a big change in see chair
or you can have one that's not very
responsive that's pretty flat anything
is pretty as admissible as long as the
the system itself is symmetric the
disadvantage is really all around the
counterfactual at least in terms of this
specific measure as I said we can talk
about the the the notion of how
predictable votes are by party later on
so it assumes a world that doesn't exist
right and as you get further out from
the hypothetical the counterfactual that
you're proposing it becomes more and
more misleading if you're if the actual
vote chair is 53% you know flipping it
to 53% the other direction or moving it
to 50% or what-have-you is not is not a
you know a terribly big lift it's not
it's not hard to imagine that might
actually occur in real elections but if
a party has 60% of the vote it's really
hard to imagine that they would the the
other party would suddenly get 60% of
the vote that this doesn't really happen
and it's not clear that the plan would
be designed
- primarily to envision that particular
scenario so it's it becomes more
problematic as you get as the
counterfactual becomes more extreme so
as the counterfactual applause blending
is the big question and this this gets
at what I think this particular measure
emerged from it's basically what they
call the drunkards search you know I
don't if you've heard this joke but
there's a guy who's drunk guys searching
for his wallet under the lamplight and
in this case I guess a cop comes up and
says were you looking for he's like I'm
looking for my wallet and he's like oh
so you've lost it somewhere around here
he's like no I lost it over there but
the lights better here right so the
principle behind Gelman King biases we
really know that a violation of majority
can mature the majority rule right is is
a pretty serious normative violation
everybody seems to agree on that and so
that's the one sort of votes aggregate
vote seats relationship issue that
everybody seems to be on the same page
about so let's just measure it they're
right let's measure that even if that's
not where the action really is in the
system the other potential problem with
Gelman came bias for this from the
perspective of the courts is that the
advocates for it have not offered any
thresholds for saying okay above this
point it's a gerrymander and below that
point it's not how much is too much
right the this is not in my view an
actual problem with the measure it's a
problem with the advocates of the
measure because you could conceivably
offers such thresholds they just haven't
done it conveniently enough these are
actually also Kennedy's concerns and
he's the swing vote here right and so he
says this is what I don't like about
Gelman King bias he says okay so this
brief for one of the amici proposes a
symmetry standard that would measure bla
bla bla okay we are wary of adopting a
constitutional standard that invalidates
a map based on unfair results that would
occur in a hypothetical state of affairs
so this is the counterfactual problem
more fundamentally you don't have a
threshold how much part is the dominance
is too much another possible measure is
to compare the mean of the districts the
distribution of district outcomes to the
median and the idea here and just take
the difference between the two of them
the intuition the idea is that in a
symmetric distribution these two things
will be equal so this is really just I
think of it as another version of
symmetry one that is a little simpler to
calculate yeah the the district that
divides the distribution in half the
distribution of so if you if you arrayed
all the districts from the least
Democratic to the most democratic it's
the median of that distribution of
district outcomes of vote outcomes sorry
[Music]
so so I think of the advantages and
disadvantages of this particular measure
is as being almost the same as Gellman
king bias it's it is easier to calculate
because you don't actually do the
counterfactual you can just calculate
the mean and the median of the
distribution but I also think the values
the values end up being vote denominated
instead of seat denominated and so I
think it's a little they're a little
less intuitive but but it is a potential
alternative the efficiency gap is the
one that I came up with and offered to
the courts and its base it comes at this
from a different direction it says all
right well if votes are in a
single-member district system you have a
certain number of votes that are wasted
in the sense that they don't contribute
directly to a victory so you have the
votes in excess of the number that you
need to win and any vote for a loser and
so the efficiency gap just says all
right well both parties should have
roughly equal wasted votes if they don't
then it means one is winning it seats
more efficiently than the other it's
it's it's getting more seats for the
same
vote chair and that's a problem
and so the efficiency gap is just the
difference between one party's wasted
votes and another is divided by the
total votes cast and when you do that it
turns out that it you end up with this
but it's more sort of simplified version
where you don't actually have to
calculate all the wasted votes it turns
out it's just the seat margin above 50%
minus 2 times the Volm are gence oh it
implies a very specific vote seats
relationship of two to one every time
you get an extra 1% of the vote
you should get an extra 2% of the seats
so it it it's not as flexible as Gelman
came biases right it requires a
particular level of responsiveness the
advantages of the efficiency gap it
doesn't require counterfactual you can
calculate it with the actual election
results and so in that sense it's it's
okay for competitive and uncompetitive
states again if you had an uncompetitive
state the counterfactual for the Galman
came bias becomes becomes problematic it
becomes a too much of an extrapolation
and it's very good at measuring what
what I what I call efficiency which is
that if you have a constant boat chair
and you were winning more seats a party
should look better off under that metric
turns out that with Gelman came bias and
media indifference in many cases because
of the and the actual counterfactual in
Gelman came bias and the implied
counterfactual in mean the mean median
difference you can often have the case
where a party can win more seats without
winning more votes and it will actually
look better off or excuse me work worse
off as a result under one of these other
measures so this was I developed this
measure as a way of trying to trying to
address that particular problem and also
so just so happens that the not I think
because just it's a happy coincidence
not because of any sort of deeper
mathematical design the two to one seats
to votes really ratio actually fits the
historical pattern quite well so you
don't have to ask the courts to to
completely undo the
the status quo in every respect and we
have offered potential thresholds for
deciding when is too much based on the
the size of the and durability of the of
the efficiency gap for any particular
plan and the size part is based on the
historical record what what has
typically been seen in past elections
and I've done some work to extend the
efficiency gap to scenarios like
variations in turnout across districts
and more than two parties so it has that
a certain flexibility to in that sense
this advantages the biggest one I think
is that it's a relatively untested idea
and so is it really the best way or the
only way to aggregate wasted votes and I
think the answer is really no that there
I've seen some arguments that that
produce just simple proportionality for
instance using similar kinds of
principles but again proportionality
would be problematic for the courts but
but in terms of measure of efficiency it
might be just as good so it's really
it's relatively untested in that sense
and we don't know if there's any big
surprises that might you know unhappy
surprises that might emerge yeah so a
wasted vote is votes in excess of the
number you need to win a seat and votes
cast for a loser so they don't translate
directly into a win in any particular
district so they're kind of they're sort
of useless in that sense in that
particular district and it really
requires a strong commitment to this
idea of wasted votes like if there's
something problematic about that you
don't necessarily want to balance that I
that concept right you have to it
doesn't it doesn't have the same kind of
deep normative history that this sort of
majority rural idea does in our system
and the efficiency gap tends to because
it works with actual election results
whereas the as long as the shape of the
distribution doesn't change Gellman king
bias and the mean median difference will
will be
immune to changes in votes over time but
the but the efficiency gap isn't
necessarily can be constant as the vote
share shifts as long as it's that two to
one ratio but it doesn't have to be and
it can vary quite a bit and I don't
personally view this as a as a flaw I
think if you buy into the idea of wasted
votes and think that that makes sense as
a measure of gerrymandering relative
wasted votes then then that's the the
variability and the metric is just a
property of the underlying concept
you're measuring yeah yes I I suppose
that's possible it doesn't as a
practical matter you don't tend to see
that kind of dynamic at at the at the at
the level of legislative and
congressional districts turnout is
driven by largely by top of the ticket
races yeah oh I see what you're saying
like if it's a blowout yeah I know that
that could be this this metric uses the
the actual election results as to sort
of reveal preferences for that district
which as we're talking about that's not
a hundred percent right yeah I mean I I
think as a practical matter the the blow
out phenomenon is also like people tend
to turn out for a presidential election
because the presidential election is
exciting for instance and it's a
gubernatorial senatorial might be a
different story but for presidential for
instance that's know and of course you
could have the same phenomenon on the
other side right it's if it appears like
it's going to be a blowout then the
other side be like God why should I show
up right the state's just released
that's what most states require so that
the geographical tie is very significant
and if you're measuring gerrymandering
measuring it against election results
with a particular geographical partition
of the state and the question is if you
change the partition as you have you
introduced something which is going to
make the representation that's a
selection of districts voting produce
something which would be unfair in
something and the question then becomes
so there is this this variability for as
a potential issue it's certainly
something that that it gets criticized
for a lot but like I said I I personally
feel like it's not quite as big a deal
so the last one I'm going to talk about
today is simulations computer
simulations and this is where I you you
basically have a computer draw a bunch
of random redistricting plans and these
plans are usually constrained to to
satisfy some criteria usually some sort
of geographic base criteria like they
got it the districts have to be compact
they can't split too many cities and
counties you can also add in and it's to
certain extent you can add in minority
representation although usually the way
that's done is they just take the
current districts that were drawn to
satisfy the Voting Rights Act and they
freeze them in place and do the
simulations around those districts and
then you get a distribution of of
outcomes of plans and you can calculate
for each of those simulated plans you
can calculate all these other metrics
that I presented here and then you can
compare the actual plan to this
distribution and see if it's an outlier
and then if it's an outlier you can say
well that suggests maybe the geography
of the state has not dictated that this
particular plan be drawn or certainly
hasn't
have been drawn by accident because if
you think about it
Democrats tend to thinking about this
concept of wasted votes Democrats tend
to live in central cities for reasons
that have nothing to do with
gerrymandering they just like to live in
central cities and so they run up the
table and districts that are drawn in
those in those cities and if you want to
draw a district that's nice and compact
then not hung you know not crazy shapes
then you're probably going to have to
draw some districts that are have very
high vote totals for Democrats and that
ends up wasting votes for Democrats and
creates a sort of natural bias in favor
of Republicans because the out in the
countryside and things tend to be a
little more balanced between the two
tend to tilt Republican right so this
these simulations get at that idea they
say well okay let's figure out to the
best of our ability what that underlying
geography is so that we can base our our
evaluation of the plan on that the the
advantages of is that well first it
gives a pretty good sense I think of a
state's political geography and it also
therefore can be a pretty good measure
of intent because one defense might be
we were just trying to draw districts
that were compact and this biased plan
emerged by accident you know what are we
supposed to do but if you got this
distribution of potential outcomes you
can say well no you know turns out that
that what you drew even if there is a
natural bias what you drew is an outlier
the disadvantage is what what they're
people who are working in this area and
this is a very active area of research
right now are really trying to figure
out whether these simulations really
sample the entire set of potential plans
there's no mathematical proof that says
that they do the problem is extremely
complex and actually the simulations
right now when you try to make them too
complex they can blow up there's a
there's a woman at
at University of Illinois who is running
these on supercomputers and she can she
can't and she and she allows all kinds
of stuff to be included not just
compactness and cities and counties and
and freezing VRA districts in place she
she's she's much more sophisticated than
that but at the moment she can only do
like a 100-seat legislature before the
whole thing blows up so so it's a very
complex problem and it freezes
apparently it crashes so so hunter would
be enough for some cases for sure like
for instance California has 80 people 80
seats in its assembly but there are some
that have you know 150 upwards of 200
the new hampshire is the outlier they
have 400 medicine which is crazy given
the size of the state right so each one
represents just their neighbors
basically the other the other potential
issue with with the simulations is can
you really say that a distribution of
outcomes has particular normative force
and by that I mean let's let's imagine a
state that's evenly divided between the
two parties 50 50 50 in terms of the
aggregate outcome but the distribution
of simulations suggests a bias in favor
of Republicans that's pretty substantial
then and let's imagine that out of the
kindness of their hearts the Republican
legislature decides to draw a plan or
maybe it's a commission or something
they decide to draw up a plan that
actually Awards both parties 50% of the
seats everybody would pretty much agree
that that's fair again going back to the
gallon came by its idea but if this if
the if the median of the distribution is
somewhere over here in a biased space
and you could draw a plan that still
manages that is in that distribution but
it's out at the tails and so it still
satisfies all the criteria about
compactness
cities and counties and so forth but it
happens to be an outlier would you want
to then redraw a plan that follows in
the meeting of the distribution I think
most people would say no which tells you
that the distribution is telling you
something but it doesn't have an
independent of some deeper notion of
fairness it doesn't actually have a
normative force so as I put it here it's
like does it matter if a plan is
improbable if it's fair if you can get
if you get an outcome in the
distribution and it's and it's out on
the tails is that a problem if it's if
it's one that in some other deeper sense
is fair and it turns out that Kennedy
agrees with me on this too he says even
those criteria that might seem promising
at the outset contiguity and compactness
cannot promise political neutrality a
decision under these standards would
unavoidably have significant political
effect whether intended or not if we
were to demand the congressional
districts take a particular shape we
could not assure the parties that this
criterion neutral enough on its face
would not in fact benefit one political
party or the other so if you were to go
just with the median of that
distribution you might end up producing
a bias and Kennedy doesn't like that
idea so where did this all get us with
guilty Woodford well just briefly about
the background of the of the case in
2010 the Republicans took control the
Wisconsin Legislature and they also won
the governor's seat so they had control
of the whole process in a redistricting
year for the first time in a gazillion
years so they were very excited and so
they they decided quite consciously to
draw a map that that aggressively
maximized the number of seats that they
could win and it by by all accounts it
worked pretty well in 2012 Republicans
won just forty eight point six percent
of the vote but they got sixty out of
the ninety nine seats so again not only
a big discrepancy between votes and
seats but also a violation of majority
rule right
I think this I think this is the two
party boat that I calculated here so
48.6 yeah there's always a few that are
but but this is the the two party and if
you calculate all these other metrics
for the Wisconsin plan they're all
really high values all three of them
this is so the the plaintiffs expert
witness Simon Jackman who actually used
to be a professor of statistics and
political science here at Stanford he's
now had gone home to his native
Australia but still involved in these
cases anyway he he calculated for all
the state legislative plans over the
last 40 years he calculated the range of
efficiency gap values for those plans
and the this red line is is the
Wisconsin plan so it's clearly an
outlier in that broader historical
distribution and you can see that a lot
of these plans end up crossing this zero
line so there's there's one of the
interesting things about the efficiency
gap is that while there there are a lot
of plans that tilt one way or the other
generally speaking they are reasonably
fair so plans that that are of high
efficiency gaps and or and don't show
any indication they're going to cross
that zero point are relatively rare this
is just showing how the this is based on
plans that the Wisconsin Legislature
drew as they are working their way
through the redistricting process they
started this is the status quo map when
they started and its efficiency gap
value is negative three percent and then
as as they this is it through time as
they drew new maps it became more and
more biased as they were looking for
ways to win more seats and the
efficiency gap well if you win more
seats without winning more votes
you will always get a higher efficiency
got value in your favor and this is the
result of the simulations the sky Jo HN
at Michigan did so that's just the mass
of the simulated values for in this case
efficiency gap but you could do it he
calculated it just for C chair too and
that's the redistricting plan that the
Wisconsin Legislature do and you can all
see on the on the y axis is the number
of counties that remained in intact so
it's a measure of geographic compound
goodgoodgood Geographic principles right
and he did this for a number of other
potential measures compactness and
splitting cities and so forth and it
turns out that act 43 ends up down in
the in the corner every time and of
course you would expect this
distribution to be higher up because
it's designed to be that way right the
simulations are designed to try and not
splitting counties if they can help it
so where do we go next well as I
mentioned at the outset I think there's
a potential challenge here there's a
culture clash this is a quote from the
oral arguments it happens to also quote
my amicus brief so I I like to show it
for that reason because it's always it's
always nice to be body slammed by a
Supreme Court justice he says if you're
the intelligent man on the street and
the court issues a decision and let's
say the Democrats win and that person
will say well why do the Democrats win
and the answer is going to be because
the eg was greater than seven percent
where eg is the Sigma party X wasted
votes blah blah blah and the intelligent
man on the street is gonna say that's a
bunch of baloney so he's worried about
how this is going to look outside of the
court and this kind of made me think if
the court needs social science to solve
a problem as I was saying I think they
did in this case does that mean that
they can't solve it because simple
straightforward concepts don't need
social science to be worked through and
complex concepts would likely fail
Roberts man-on-the-street
so can the court act on complex measures
without compromising its legitimacy I
don't I don't want to dismiss I mean a
lot of people have really dismissed
Roberts comments out of hand I don't
necessarily want to do that I think it's
a legitimate question you know there's
there's a question of the of the of the
integrity of the court that's at stake
here and I don't think it should be
dismissed lightly I didn't say that I
just think we should take the issue
seriously so where do we where do we go
next with all this well I'd say each
each of these measures has some weakness
from the perspective of the courts the
Gulman came biased and mean media
indifference there have counterfactuals
the efficiency gap is very new and
untested simulations are also relatively
untested especially in the sense that we
don't know 100% for sure that they are
sampling from the full range of
potential potential plans and they
punish a state a party that is
disfavored by political geography
my sense is I don't think there actually
will be a winning metric if the court
decides to intervene my guess is what
they probably would end up doing is
either throwing it to the lower courts
to work it out or they would say you
know what our standard says that all of
these measures that have been presented
to us need to agree what's they actually
do in this case but they all need to
agree that it's a gerrymander otherwise
we're not going to get involved and so
as a practical matter the efficiency gap
and mean median bias and Gellman King
bias they all are highly correlated in
competitive states and uncompetitive
states like California for instance
they'd start they can very likely
diverge and so if that were the standard
it would mean that you would it would be
harder to bring a case in an
uncompetitive state than a competitive
one so the decision is most people think
it won't come before January and it they
could wait as long as til June there are
other efforts that are underway it's not
just all about this case
so there's reform efforts in terms of
independent Commission's like the one we
have here in California and I can talk
about that if you want the there's
Florida is one state that has legal
constraints on what its legislature can
draw it says the Legislature's not
allowed to draw a plan that benefits one
party and there was a ton of litigation
over the last several years over whether
the plan that the legislature drew in
2011 actually violated that provision of
the law and I think these measures all
these measures that I've mentioned will
continue to be valuable for those kinds
of things regardless of what the court's
decision ends up being sort of bright
dividing line but you know as you get
further out from a competitive plan or
competitive state I should say then the
counterfactual becomes larger and and
the the potential for sort of strange
results increases yeah I mean I would
say both simulate the simulations and
the efficiency gap can can handle states
that are uncompetitive again if you as
long as you buy all their their
assumptions the other I would not
personally use the other two for an
uncompetitive state at all there's also
a very interesting measure that I just
saw recently called that's even newer
than the efficiency gap that's called
declination and the idea there is you
line up all of the districts in a state
from the least Democratic to the most
democratic and if you line them up that
way then on in terms of their their vote
share on the y-axis they should be they
should be pretty much aligned you know
more or less should you should be
aligned there should be no reason why
you have an inflection point and that
line right at 50% or close to 50% and if
you do then that means somebody was
really concerned about 50% when they
were drawing the plan right and I think
you know I haven't explored it
completely but I think it seems very
promising to me it seems like it might
be a good measure of intent in
particular that doesn't have the problem
of the of the question of you know are
we really sampling from the full
distribution of seeds you're saying have
an algorithm replace the oh I see the
problem is you don't necessarily know
what the algorithm is algorithm is that
they used right yes so you could put two
you could put something in the law that
says here's what how we want maps to be
drawn the exact process that it needs to
follow
I actually think one of the most
promising things for the simulations is
as a tool not not as an not as an
evaluation tool but as a tool for
generating districts especially like if
a court has to intervene and sit down
and draw a good map in a short period of
time they could have the computer
produce a bunch of maps and then they
could they could say you know what give
me only the maps that satisfy this you
know clear this threshold on these
measures right I'm sort of optimize
based on the simulations and then you
would have a group that you could work
from and that's sort of like an
algorithm in a sense and you could you
could potentially put something like
that into the law as well I suppose
and that would allow the sort of human
element of redistricting to still to
still be there because there is
there is an element of you know their
communities of interest and so forth
that don't necessarily have anything to
do with parties but or with you know
race or anything else but but it would
it would allow you to sort of get that
pool of potential options in front of
you so that you could choose between
them yeah dis routine with a this is the
way by which organized both the thrown
away whatever seems to me is a simply
merge everything into a single history
and then have multiple representatives
from the district and allocate the
representatives to a particular cohort
based upon voting behavior or something
on that hill and things that well I
think if you turn everything into one
district I think at that point then you
should switch to a different system
entirely because then you're saying
geography is not what we're really
concerned about and what we and sort of
it we're admitting the parties or where
it's at and that's how a lot of systems
operate right and then they have again
they have some they have some some
decision rule for how the votes get
allocated and turned into seats and
there's a variety of different voting
systems that can produce that kind of
that can work in that kind of system but
but once you get to that one big
district thing I think you you move into
that world and as you in fact as you
move because you can also have
multi-member districts right that are
sort of an in-between yeah yeah and so
as as you as you move away from the
single-member district universe and
start getting into larger and larger
multi-member districts I think it
becomes more and more sensible to have
an alternative decision rule but that's
the challenges that's a really tough nut
to crack in terms of reform right
it's just just harassing because you're
gonna have to go through Congress and
all likelihood to do that and then that
requires members of Congress to change
the way that they were elected which is
tough to do is that when the opinion
gets released
so my like I said my guess is that they
that they won't that if the efficiency
gap has played a role in this case it's
to make the court feel more comfortable
getting involved not not offering them
the rosetta stone as it was often
referred to derisive Lea in the oral
arguments I don't think it's a rosetta
stone I think it can be very very useful
metric but I wouldn't I wouldn't expect
the court to want to step in and because
if they say okay yeah it's got to be the
efficiency gap this thing that first
appeared in print three years ago right
then there now diff now they are
stepping in and defending it right now
it's now they put their their integrity
on the line and it's not just me right
so so I would be really surprised if
they did if they took that step again my
guess is because all the metrics agree
in this particular case they won't feel
such pressure to choose between the
metrics and they will find some way to
avoid doing that even if they get
involved now the other part of your
question that I think is what do I think
is gonna happen I guess I would say
going into the oral arguments I did I
get I did get to go and sit in the
audience which was fun but going into
the oral arguments I I would have
probably given it maybe a 35% chance of
success of the striking down the maps
but based on the the questioning and and
in particular Kennedy's line of
questioning I'd maybe say it even tilts
in favor of the plaintiffs now so not a
lot but because it's again it's it this
is
this is a heavy lift for the court to
want to get involved in this area so we
should never expect it to be a slam dunk
they are saying that there is person
gerrymandering we've found so what it be
that they don't know like they're not
good that's a very good question
I think it I mean what the plaintiffs at
they're sort of at the most basic level
what the plaintiffs were were asking the
court to do was to admit that this if
there is such a thing as a parties in
gerrymander that this one is one right
and and and then they were they were
trying not to commit themselves too much
to any one particular metric at that at
the district court level they went whole
hog on the efficiency gap and I thought
that was great and very exciting and all
but I think the strategy once they got
to the Supreme Court was was very
sensible it's like not don't don't
commit yourself to any one thing too
much especially because they all agree
and and you know whether that I mean
that there is precedent for the idea of
saying you know what we think that we
know that whatever metric we end up
choosing clearly this one is an outlier
and so we can say that there's a problem
here and that actually Accords quite
well with what they did in the in the
redistricting cases in the 1960s where
the issue was not partisan
gerrymandering but it was differences in
population between districts some
districts were wildly larger than others
and the one the really big ones had a
disadvantage because they all they you
know even though they had more people
they only got one representative so they
had a disadvantage relative to the small
ones and there's this massive
malapportionment and so the court
intervened to force all the districts to
have the same population but they didn't
decide on what that what that precise
test was going
b4 it turns out it ends up being like
congressional districts need to be they
can only vary by like five people right
I mean it became very very tight right
but but that's not where it started out
it started out with we think this is
justiciable and we're going to strike
down this plan and then they saw a
variety of cases after that that worked
their way up to the courts where they
saw the full range of possible cases
that were out there and then they made
their decision about thresholds and so
forth on that basis and it took them a
number of years to do it and it might be
similar something similar with this as
well so yeah has been used to target
individuals either to prop up the head
of the party in control or to spot the
troublemakers in the opposing party and
redraw their specific districts and a
way to make sure they're gonna have more
fun being reelected yes yeah I I may not
have been paying close attention but
they are your plans trying to factor
that I know this is all about parties
there's a whole other dimension to
gerrymandering that's very personal and
nasty and and there's nothing to do with
necessarily with any of this so I mean
it's a good question is it it's really
like it's important to realize what
these are meant to measure and what
they're not right and this is really all
about parties and not about anything
else that's what you're trying to
achieve see I'm thinking there's some
logic problems that have to do with
things like two people want to split
blueberry pie and you know how do you
cut it and one of the answers is well
one person cuts that been half and the
other person says which of the Habs he
wants and that way the first person is
motivated to be very careful in the
cutting because he doesn't want to have
a choice that gives the chooser and
I there must be an infinity number of
ways to do you know many infinities of
ways to do this redrawing and coming up
with any algorithm that was going to do
that using some automated thing couldn't
possibly factor in all the issues like
to what extent a party leader is being
protected or attacked yeah I know that's
why I think that is never imagined to be
I mean I guess you could try to embed
that into the simulations but it doesn't
you know it's well the blueberry pie
analogy might be instead of having some
algorithm come up with the mappings and
by each party to submit what it thinks
is a fair mapping and then have an
evaluation of each of the two or each of
the three proposals to figure out which
ones least fair and reject that such
that the person that was working towards
more moderation is rewarded for taking a
moderate perspective and that was motive
yeah there are games to have a moderate
approach and I think again there is a
distinction between possible reform
efforts there's all kinds of different
ECOD do in terms of reform and what the
courts want to do and how they're going
to be involved and the court that the
Constitution Awards state legislatures
of each state the the right to draw the
district's so there's a certain
deference that is given to them under
the law and the courts don't have the
ability to to invent new reforms to make
redistricting work better all they can
do is impose constraints and say this
one is out of bounds right and so it
could be that in in many of these cases
if a plan is struck down the courts will
decide given the amount of time that's
available to pass it to some special
masters it happens all the time it
usually involves finding some legal
expert or retired judges or something to
draw the district's instead of the
legislature because it just really isn't
the time to do it properly and maybe
they don't trust the legislature at that
point to do it but you first have to
have that litigation to establish that
you're going to hand it to a special
masters
and then when you hand it to the Special
Master the Special Master could decide
to do it any way they wanted to right
they could say what you're talking about
hey let's get both parties to submit
plans and all decide the best one or
something along those lines but but but
the court the courts are constrained in
sort of how they can approach this
problem yeah people were trying really
hard and are really good people
generally know what median and mean are
about well the person on the street
probably doesn't but there's a huge
population of people who do and that
comes from a long history of dealing
with it seems to make a lot of sense to
me because right now probably people
don't have a good sense of what people I
mean more than just the people who
created it may not have a very strong
sense of how the these different
measures interact or or distinguish and
so having an array of them seems like
goodness because they to the extent they
tend to agree then they tend to make a
stronger case and so even if maybe I
don't like this one that much or I like
this one too much there's still an
overall case the the larger point that
occurs to me is what you've what you've
been talking about is oddly not very
social its outcome-based and in that
sense of course it is but you made
references to a little bit of the
demographics coming into play but they
aren't really the focus and so the
nature of the people who were doing the
voting and care about the outcome isn't
really in the mix and for no particular
reason I'm choosing to take Roberts
concern about man-on-the-street as a
plea for
what I'm afraid I have to call marketing
which is figuring out how to explain
this stuff in a way that makes sense if
not to literally everybody on the street
to enlarge enough body of people that we
have a similar degree of comfort with
that as we do with me median and mode
and other complex cars mm-hmm yeah no
that makes sense and I mean I think if I
were gonna describe the efficiency gap
in the simplest terms possible I would
say it's about vote dilution vote
dilution everybody having their every
party having their votes count the same
the you know for the other like the mean
median difference and go any bias to say
it's about majority and trench men like
I said so I think there are ways that
you can you can describe them that maybe
simplifies them but I agree with you
that it's that it's a that it there is
an issue of marketing here and I tend to
to not be very good at that I like Maya
my co-author on wait so I I develop the
efficiency gap and then I teamed up with
this legal scholar to write a paper to
turn it into a legal test and he's so
much better at that kind of stuff than I
am and including his actually his wife
came up with the name efficiency gap I
called it relative wasted votes
originally and she's also a lawyer and
she was like no that's terrible
it should be efficient do something else
[Music]
doing it on a statewide basis right so
well you know ends up being statewide
yeah right those it all works out the
same right so I mean it sorry I just
wanted to make sure I understand it the
right way it seems it seems to me you
can envision a stage where there are one
or two very democratic urban centers
super geographically polarized and
there's a lot of Kerry man
in you know a few of those districts
that sort of lend themselves to that but
then you know you go out into the rural
areas and it doesn't really matter if
you know how you draw the district's it
secure whelmingly Republican so I'm just
wondering how the wondering if this kind
of overall statewide kind of measurement
system I'm wondering whether that
adequately sort of takes into account
the kind of geographical sorting that
also contributes to this problem and
whether it kind of it all sort of
averages out mathematically or whether
the whether it be sometimes we might
just sort of gloss over those those sort
of geographical differences well so the
first thing is that in your in your
description you the Republican areas
would have to be sort of somewhat
Republican if they were overwhelmingly
Republican then they were overwhelmingly
Republican here would balance out what
the overall and many Democratic here and
you'd end up with something that was
probably pretty fair actually unbalanced
but so there's a problem the problem
right now in our current politics is
that Democrats are packed in central
cities and then there are a certain
number of Democrats out in the
countryside but just not quite as many
as Republicans and so it's easier to
draw those kind of narrow margin winds
out there so but then getting at your at
your larger point I think the problem
with thinking about it as sections of
the state and so forth is that again the
whole point of a party is to try and
knit people in different parts of the
state together into a coalition that's
going to be able to act effectively in
the legislature as a whole and a party
wants more seats wherever it can get
them and what it cares about for the
outcomes and the legislators the total
number seats that they have in the
entire state it doesn't really matter if
they if they win you know some here and
then lose some other over there that
would could be considered a net zero for
them and if a plan actually does produce
sort of a net zero gain then it's not
really a gerrymander right so I think
that that aggregate when you're talking
about parties and to be fair like there
are there are there's a lawsuit in
Maryland
that is specifically trying to take a
district based approach and saying this
district was drawn in a funny way in
order to try and elect a Democrat and
that's a problem and that's what a
gerrymander is if you have a particular
district or a set of districts and that
district based approach is more in line
with the way that the courts have
thought about other kinds of
gerrymandering in the past so racial
gerrymandering has typically been
thought of as specific districts so this
district was drawn to be a racial
gerrymander right and not not an
aggregate thing and that came up in the
oral arguments it was one of the
questions that there's a question of
standing in this case where the the
court is wants to know is it even
appropriate to bring a statewide claim
or does this does a claim about
gerrymandering have to be district
specific and the answer that they that
they gave and the answer that I would
give is that again parties are
inherently an aggregate concept and
people who are you know in the central
cities care about how many people are
elected from their parties out in the
countryside because they want their
party as a whole to do better even if
they themselves are in a district that's
nice and compact and you know that
elects a candidate that they like and
that's of their choice in that sense
that you really do have to think about
it in those broader aggregate terms but
that might be another way in which it's
an it's an non-starter for the courts
that might be one of the the way that
they would decide this case in fact is
to say you know it can't be an aggregate
approach yeah so they the Commission was
created in the latter part of the last
decade and was used for the first time
in 2011 the process for picking the
commissioners is is very complicated it
starts with the state auditor who
submits requests applications from
anybody who's a registered voter in the
state so the first time
Commission it received like 30,000
applications
the state auditor had to go all through
all those and figure out and whittle it
down and so then they Whittle it down to
a smudge smaller pool they interview
that smaller pool and then they would a
little bit down further and then they
give the members of the legislature a
chance to strike a certain number of
names from the list and then once those
names are struck and they have their
final list then they randomly choose the
first nine I think of the 14 of the 14
members of the commission and then those
nine choose the remaining members and
then that the process of it is they have
to hold open meetings everything's got
to be open and transparent they got to
me one of the biggest things is they
have to produce a report at the end that
describes why they do reach district the
way they do it and that is I think that
is undervalued as one of the you know
one of the pluses of this kind of system
like if the legislature had to produce a
report that said why they were doing
what they were doing you know it might
it might be easier to attack them you
know in the in litigation whereas one
that when it came before the the states
of the California State Supreme Court
the the state Senate map that was drawn
by the Commission ended up before the
states the state Supreme Court and they
just went through that report and they
were like well it says here they do it
this way in this way you know they had a
record they had a justification which is
a very sort of judicial concept right
and so I think the judges really liked
that there also are some criteria in the
law that require that the districts be
drawn certain with certain issues in
mind and the the those issues are ranked
so it starts with equal population then
it goes to the Voting Rights Act and it
goes to like keeping cities and counties
intact and you know it all down the list
they actually says that they can't
consider partisan data when they're
drawing their districts so I actually
think that depending on what the Court
Rule is that might be something they
want to reconsider because if you had a
standard for the court offers a standard
for
you avoid partisan gerrymandering seems
to me the Commission should just embed
that standard in in their law and
actually use the partisan data to do
that but it's yeah so then it's it's a
it's a very open transparent process I'm
I was a little skeptical that it could
work but but I'm I'm kind of a fan now
so yeah I've been sure to say I could
make a map that would make any
particular metrics shine wonderfully in
the other ones trying that or make them
all shine good become all shine bed but
she described to me as a system that is
inherently biased because it's made with
people that all have I'm gonna randomly
pick them you know it's all
geographically based or racially based
or school based or something like that
totally random number generator base
super random man they would totally
randomized it so that all metrics were
great well so I think having a metric
based approach makes a lot of sense and
like I said I think the way that I would
prefer to do that is to is to have a
computer generated a bunch of possible
plans that were optimized on you know on
a bunch of metrics jointly and then yeah
and then but then you think there should
be a part where you once you've decided
that there that all the maps that you
got in front of you are are acceptable
and all the metrics then you you get to
choose between them and you don't have
just one choice because there are there
are other elements
I actually think one of the things that
was sensible about the Commission is
that it had a requirement that
communities of interest be respected and
communities of interest for the as it as
it played out in the
and the Commission's work just basically
meant whoever shouted the loudest right
was whoever showed up at the at the
hearings and said we're a community of
interest we need to be respected but you
know what when you're met when you're
passing a law which is what the
Commission was doing you want to take
into account passionate interests if you
don't you're going to be in trouble
you want to know who who cares the most
and you want to try and accommodate
their interest to the extent that you
can without doing violence to a lot of
other groups I mean that's a lot of what
our system of government does is trying
to make sure that that the the most
passionate voices are satisfied without
doing violence to everybody else and
that sometimes works and it sometimes
doesn't but yeah and I mean I think
that's multiple metrics but at least one
of them is odd in subsets we're running
out of time thank you very much we'll
continue the discussion
[Applause]
you